[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans cette campagne d'entre deux
tours nous continuons de vous faire
vivre les meetings de les décrypter de
les analyser et nous allons suivre dans
quelques instants le meeting des manuels
macron le candidat dans marche arrivé en
tête au premier tour dimanche soir et et
hier soir arras nous allons si son
discours en intégralité dans quelques
instants
et pour commenter et analyser ce
discours et la campagne d'entre deux
tour d'emmanuel macron deux invités
notre chroniqueur économique jean louis
gombeaud bonjour rien notre
éditorialiste politique ni kms bonjour
yale
alors michael un ce meeting hier soir
harassé bien il arrivait au terme d'une
journée marquée par le duel entre marine
le pen et emmanuel macron ah oui en
poule 1 mais quelle journée
peut-être un tournant de la campagne on
sait jamais il ya eu trois temps enfin
dans cette journée est tout d'abord eu
l'image de l'intersyndicale avec
emmanuel macron dans une pièce enfermé
de discussion de fond certainement et
puis deuxième temps la surprise marine
le pen qui arrive devant l'usiné
nouvelle poule avec les salariés les
selphy les retours avec avec toutes les
personnes sur place et embrassades
bref des images transmises en direct sur
les chaînes d'information et qui ont
montré qu emmanuel macron finalement
était un petit peu pris 1,20 piège c'est
vrai qu'elle a voulu créer cette
surprise est allé au contact de la
population en disant d'ailleurs moi je
vais au contact emmanuel macron lui il
est enfermé dans une pièce et ne peut
pas venir devant cette usine et puis
troisième temps de cette journée
emmanuel mâcon quasiment obligé de venir
devant sa cuisine et de discuter pendant
une heure et demie avec les salariés au
contact au plus près des salariés et
finalement hué à son arrivée et il est
reparti en serrant des mains avec un ton
beaucoup plus calme dans sa cuisine avec
avec les salariés et on peut dire
finalement que quelque part
marine le pen a rendu quelque peu un
service à emmanuel macron qu'elle l'a
elle l'a sorti un petit peu de cette
torpeur du début de deuxième tour
d'entre deux tours et que finalement et
bien il est finalement entré dans cette
campagne d'entre deux tours de cette
surprise qu'a voulu faire marine le pen
est sortie peut-être une forme de
reconquête pour emmanuel macron au tuc à
médiatiquement parlant il est sorti
gagnant hier de cette joute médium est
ce que cette journée ça cet affrontement
rien paul et bien
pas illustré est symbolisée de stratégie
de campagne qui sont radicalement
opposés tout casser front contre front
ça c'est évident et marine le pen a
décidé d'aller au plus près des français
au plus près du candidat de ne marquer
si vous voulez un peu marquage
individuel convention doit employer une
métaphore footballistique et du coup est
venu le maquereau et b il se trouve
obligé lui aussi de répondre du tac au
tac et du coup il va cette forme
d'avertissement qu'il a reçu hier fait
dire dans l'entourage de manuel macro
que la campagne va complètement changer
que c'est lui qui doit donner le tempo
c'est lui qui doit aller jo les terres
où on vote front national et donc à lui
matt ono d'imprimer sa marque sur cette
compagnie jean-louis une usine
oui ampoules damien c'est le symbole des
délocalisations et peut-être plus
largement de cette mondialisation
est-ce que c'est aussi sur ce terrain
voire surtout sur ce terrain comme acer
cette campagne d'entre deux tours je
pense je pense madame le pen rajoutera
beaucoup sur l'immigration mais on peut
dire que ça s'intègre dans la
mondialisation
et c'est vrai que sont ces créneaux ça
va être le candidat de la patrie c'est
moi et lui c'est le candidat de la
mondialisation parce qu'il faut
extraordinaire par rapport à ce que des
et mickaël faut voir que cette
controverse qui a eu lieu hier à vire
poule venez après les commentaires d'un
début de campagne ratée de monsieur
macron s qu'effectivement il n'a pas
compris que dans ce sport il n'ya pas de
mi temps on retourne pas aux vestiaires
on n'a même pas le temps d'aller aux
toilettes il faut passer immédiatement à
l'action et madame le pen quelques
papiers lui dire vient de battre viens
te battre et je vais me battre
là où tu l'as où tu te trouves je pense
que sur le plan médiatique c'est plutôt
elle qui emporte le morceau parce que
elle arrive elle donne des solutions que
ce qu'elle appelle des solutions simples
en fin de compte j'interdis licenciement
s'il n'y a pas de repreneur l'état peut
prendre à l'entreprise en charge de
temps dans le temps d'en trouver
alors que lui est handicapé cirque on
avait l'impression quand même dans cette
histoire que madame le pen venait
exploiter là les difficultés de ces gens
mais lui il n'était pas dans
l'exploitation
il était plutôt dans l'explication or
les gens n'attendent pas d'explication
ils attendent une solution et
là ils étaient obligés parce qu'il ne
veut pas aller comme sur le terrain de
madame le pen dustan c'est très simple
je ferme les frontières jeu mais l'âme
l'état prendra en main ce qui est de mon
point de vue en tout cas à la limite du
grotesque mais lui il est sans solution
qu est qu est ce qu il leur dit pas ce
qu'il ya un problème vous dites c'est la
moins d'illusions c'est exact voilà
entreprises gagnent de l'argent qui va
en gagner plus en pologne parce que les
gens sont payés 2 euros 8 de leurs et
qui va ré exporter une partie de cette
production en france
parce qu'il n'ya c'est un nous sommes
dans un marché unique et qui en plus a
touché le seuil c'est eux
donc les gens ne comprennent pas il a
ils ont touché lui c est le cic ils ont
acheté des machines ses machines avec ce
6e pour les transporter en pologne
ils sont en situation est effectivement
dans cette affaire monsieur ma
compassion il n'a même pas dit il faut
pousser l'europe à l'est vers
l'égalisation social présent il n'a même
pas avancer cette cette solution auquel
quand on entend jean louis
dire marine le pen a gagné la bataille
médiatique finalement est-ce qu'elle n'a
pas battu emmanuel macron sur son propre
terrain sur ce qui a fait son atout
durant la campagne du premier tour cette
bataille de la communication bataille de
communication qui est évidemment là où
il ya eu ce piège effectivement lancée
par marine le pen marine le pen à
l'expérience prenne la peine qu'elle
fait de la politique et des combats
politiques et des combats d'élections à
ça elle sait faire emmanuel macron c'est
sa première alors est ce que c'est un
problème avec son entourage
est-ce qu'ils étaient pris au piège de
l'entre-deux-tours effectivement de
lundi où il est resté bloqué dans son qg
quasiment tout le temps afin dé réunion
a analysé comme il dit à réfléchir pour
la suite il ya eu un petit retard à
l'allumage
maintenant c'est peut être l'heure de la
contre attaque qui veut mener mais là
revenait à faire face à face entre eux
maintenant deux personnes qui s'y
connaissent aussi en terme de
communication ce qu'il a fait hier quand
il est allé à la au contact des salariés
et où ils ont montré une certaine image
de lui de fermeté peut-être jean-louis
vous direz peut-être un peu l' inverse
tout cas de négociation de discussion on
a là quelqu'un qui travaille sur le fond
quelqu'un qui travaille sur la forme
après l'image elle reste bloquée
évidemment les français vont rester
bloqué sur une idée de ce qu'ils se font
de cette image
après cette visite en pologne 1 emmanuel
macron et donc aller arras pour tenir
son premier meeting de cette campagne
d'entre deux tours un discours que nous
allons suivre tout c'est en intégralité
et on revient juste après pour
l'analyser
j'avais quitté les hauts de france
depuis dimanche en début d'après midi
j'avais oublié ce que c'était
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous merci pour votre
enthousiasme et pour votre accueil
je devais être avec vous vendredi
dernier c'était attendez je crois qu'il
ya des gens qui ne voient pas il faut de
la discipline
[Musique]
est ce que tout le monde voit et entend
on ira jusqu'au bout et donc vendredi
j'avais dû malheureusement annulée cette
visite est ce rassemblement suite aux
odieux attentat que notre pays avait
subi dans la soirée de jeudi
je m'en excuse et je vous avait alors
fait passer un message mais à défaut
d'avoir fait ici arras le dernier
rassemblement avant le premier tour nous
ferons ensemble
le premier rassemblement de cet entre
deux tours
[Applaudissements]
et nous allons le faire mes amis avec
encore plus de force de joie et de
gravité que nous ne l'aurions fait il y
a sans doute quelques jours encore parce
que je veux d'abord commencer par nommer
ce qui s'est passé l'état du pays le
moment où nous sommes et je voulais le
faire ici parce que ces termes sont
chères parce que notre mouvement il a
commencé à quelques kilomètres j étais
tout à l'heure à amiens dans les hauts
de france 2 je viens et parce que les
terres où nous sommes c'est r2o de
france
elles sont au coeur de notre histoire de
notre passé et du défi politique qui est
aujourd'hui le nôtre
que s'est il passé dimanche dernier
les françaises et les français ont
décidé de tourner une page de la vie
politique
ils ont décidé que les deux grands
partis de gouvernement qui jusqu'àlors
avait tenu le pays
il ne se reconnaissait plus en oeuvre un
quart simplement des françaises et des
français se sont portés sur ces partis
et je le dis avec respect pour les
militants respect pour les élus respect
pour les engager ce que nous sommes tous
des engagés de la vie démocrate de la
vie démocratique française
mais quelque chose s'est passé dont
notre pays était gros une page a été
tournée
ces deux grands partis ne peuvent plus
structuré la vie politique française
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
alors j'entends les voix qui voudrait
qu'on en jambes cette élection qu'ils
disent
le sujet n'est même plus le front
républicain sont des balivernes
on ne l'entend même pas cette formule et
qui ne pensent que législatives avec une
indécence incroyable qui n'écoute même
pas ce que les françaises et les
français ont dit et aux aujourd'hui
encore expliqué mais moi je suis prêt à
venir demain gouverner parce que j'aurai
une majorité parlementaire
ils n'ont pas compris que la refondation
est profonde et que le moment que nous
vivons est bien plus important bien plus
grave que les intérêts des uns ou des
autres
quel qu'il soit y compris nous mêmes
ensuite un quart des françaises et
français se sont exprimés dans des votes
plus protestataire difficiles qui ont
aussi fragilisé ces partis de
gouvernement plus traditionnel et il
faut regarder en face que plusieurs
candidats emporté et en particulier jean
luc mélenchon et je sais que peut-être
beaucoup dans cette salle beaucoup dans
cette région hôte aussi suivi sa
candidature ou pu voter pour lui
nocifs les personnes ne sifflait surtout
pas d'abord ça n'est pas nous de sifflet
et surtout il a été un candidat tout à
fait digne il a supporté la question
démocratique la question écologique ses
propres idées avec beaucoup de panache
et il a soulevé il a soulevé dans le
pays une attente il a soulevé une
adhésion qu'il faut regarder simplement
depuis dimanche soir il n'est pas à la
hauteur de cette adhésion et ses
électeurs mérite mieux que lui
et je le dis
beaucoup ne se retrouve pas dans nos
idées nous avons des désaccords mais
nous avons une chose qui vaut plus que
tout l'attachement profond viscéral de
pouvoir partager démocratiquement ses
désaccords et cela ne l'oublié pas parce
que c'est aussi ce qui est en jeu dans
ce deuxième tour
alors face à cette menace face à ceux
qui haïssent la république et créer le
désordre et la haine
choisissez un camp ne pas le choisir
c'est perdre de vue ce cadre
et donc depuis dimanche soir il n'y a
pas comme nous l'avons connu il ya
quinze ans un front républicain qui
s'est soulevée il faut bien le dire mais
c'est ainsi il n'y a pas eu cet
unanimisme du monde politique et
médiatique pour dire tout sauf non pas
monsieur
mais cette fois-ci madame le pen comme
si les uns vers les autres s'y était
habitué comme si nous avions
collectivement décidé qu'on pouvait
compromettre avec certaines idées comme
si le changement
les visages pouvait faire oublier que
les mots eux n'ont pas changé que les
aime
elles n'ont pas changé que les
turpitudes sont les mêmes
j'entends les divisions dans différents
camps et je veux ici saluer dans les
hauts de france
le premier rendez lui qui est face à moi
toutes et tous vous avez mené des
combats parfois les uns et les unes
contre les autres mais vous êtes dans
une terre qui a connu aux régionales la
menace du front national vous avez pris
vos responsabilités
frédéric en particulier le sait ici et
d'autres nombreux et vous ne voulez pas
que ça se reproduise et vous êtes là
depuis bord et je salue votre présence
venant du parti socialiste des radicaux
de l'udi du modem des républicains
venant des mouvements citoyens venant
dans marche que vous avez tous et est
monté mais nous sommes là tous ensemble
parce que c'est bien la dignité de la
france est un projet que nous voulons
porter et le visage que vous montrez là
c'est celui que je veux pour notre pays
c'est celui pendant 15 jours sans
relâche que nous allons porter parce que
oui
face à l'incapacité de certains
dirigeants ou de certains grands partis
de décider un front républicain
nous allons refonder la vie politique
française
ce que
ce que nous portons depuis avril 2016
nous allons au coeur au corps du pays
le poursuivre durant ces quinze jours de
campagne
et encore après une refondation profonde
qui construira justement ce socle où
tous les progressistes vont pouvoir
enfin travailler ensemble à visage
découvert sans hypocrisie pour l'intérêt
du pays
et je le dis à toutes celles et ceux qui
nous rejoignent après ce premier tour
comme je les dis à toutes celles et ceux
qui l'ont décidé
avant ce premier tour ils sont les
bienvenus s'ils sont les porteurs
authentique de ce projet tous les
progressistes sont les bienvenus je ne
leur demanderai jamais d'où ils viennent
je m'assurerai simplement à chaque
instant que nous voulons bien faire la
même chose pour le pays
c'est cela notre défi il n'y en a pas
d'autre
et donc je ne reproduirai pas l'erreur
faite en 2002 qui a consisté après le
front républicain à reprendre les
habitudes
nous allons les changer
les habitudes et les usages parce que
nous devons assemblée parce que la vie
politique française depuis dimanche soir
comment s'est-elle structuré et comment
est-elle structurer durablement
d'un côté le camp du front national
celui qui décide de porter le repli la
négation du monde
la haine de l'autre la sortie de
l'europe la démagogie et de l'autre la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre celle de
vouloir une france conquérante dans
l'europe et dans le monde
celle de vouloir une france qui éduque
qui fait progresser qui regardent les
difficultés en phase et il ne les écoute
pas
qui a confiance dans l'avenir qui
veulent construire et qui parle à
l'intelligence de chacune et chacun qui
ne fait pas de démagogie
depuis dimanche soir je le disais notre
joie est grave parce que notre
responsabilité est immense
je sais ce que les uns et les autres ici
vous ressentez parce que j'ai regardé
comme vous le lendemain matin les
chiffres âge était joyeux parce que les
français nous ont mis en tête et cette
joie il ne faut pas la bouder nous
n'étions rien il ya un an
il ya trois mois tout le monde se moquer
de nous mais j'ai vu sur ses terres que
je connais sur les vôtres ou vous êtes
élu engagé
vous travaillez j'ai vu les chiffres du
front national j'ai mesuré avec vous la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre celle
d'aller reconquérir ses terres celle
d'aller convaincre celle de n'accepter
aucune défaite et la première défaite ce
serait la victoire facile la victoire
donner la victoire déjà prononcés
rien ne sera comme avant rien y compris
les quinze jours qui viennent
et donc notre devoir est immense parce
que ce qui va se jouer dans les quinze
jours qui viennent sera déterminant pour
les mois et les années à venir dans
notre pays
oublier l'espace d'un instant la force
du front national la menace qu'il
représente c'est se condamner demain à
ne pas pouvoir présider à ne pas pouvoir
gouverner c'est cela que je suis venu
vous dire ce soir c'est que nous avons
été joyeux et nous pouvons l'être
nous sommes fiers et restons le les
françaises et les français veulent
l'espoir ils nous ont placés en tête
mais portons tout cela avec gravité avec
détermination parce que tout dépend de
notre capacité le 7 mai prochain à
gagner largement fortement pour changer
les choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et moi je n'ai qu'un ennemi mes amis un
ennemi ce sont aux fractures et nos
divisions
je n'accepte pas ce que j'entends depuis
dimanche soir il y aurait la france
d'ériger la france des pauvres la france
des villes et la france deschamps la
france triomphante et celle qui a déjà
perdu
il n'ya qu'une france la nôtre
mais il y à des divisions profondes des
fractures et nous devons tous ensemble
les regarder en face pour y répondre et
j'irai dans tous ses territoires de
fracture je ne laisserai pas une once du
territoire de france à madame le pen une
seconde
[Applaudissements]
face à la fracture politique qui s'est
révélé dimanche soir le vent nous allons
dans tous ces territoires qui doute qui
se disent perdu je les fais aujourd'hui
je leur ferai demain
et chaque jour il n'y en a pas ces
territoires
ce sont les territoires de france ce
dont nous venons allons partout porter
ce discours exigeant cet espoir au coeur
non pas pour promettre je ne sais quoi
mais pour dire que chacun des
territoires de la république
il est dans la république je n'en sais
pas de perdus
à cette fracture politique opposant
notre détermination notre envie le
discours de l'intelligence contre la
démagogie
j'étais tout à l'heure ce qui explique
un retard dont je m'excuse à amiens
d'abord pour voir l'intersyndicale de
whirlpool puis pour me rendre sur le
site
j'ai d'abord vu les syndicats parce que
je crois dans le dialogue social
et parce que l'intersyndicale depuis des
mois a joué un rôle formidable dont les
élus peuvent témoigner de responsabilité
pour ne pas bloquer le site pour
préserver les emplois
l'image de l'entreprise face il faut
bien le dire au cynisme et au choix
brutale j'ai passé une heure et quart
avec eux et j'ai commencé cet entretien
leur disant je sais bien vous vouliez
que je vienne avant mais je n'étais pas
n'était plus ministre et je n'allais pas
entraver le travail au demeurant bien
conduit par monsieur sirugue mon
successeur
mais est ce que ça vous aide si je vais
sur le terrain
je voulais leur réponse
deux d'entre eux m'ont dit oui sera pas
facile mais venez parce que ça nous
renforcera dans le même temps nous
apprenions que madame le pen allait sur
le parking ne siffle pas madame le pen
mais si fais pas ça ne sert à rien allez
des sorties de ce rassemblement dans
chaque maison
dans chaque café et à les convaincre
si vous êtes avec moi ce soir c'est que
vous n'allez pas d'applaudir
donc je n'ai pas besoin que vous l'a eu
lieu ne vous inquiétez pas mais madame
le pen elle est venue faire quoi elle
est venue passer un quart d'heure un
quart d'heure sur un parking avec pour
moitié des militants du front national
faire des selphy dire qu'elles
montraient une taxe spéciale aux
importations
ça s'appelle monte de 3 points la tva je
vous donne la traduction
si vous vouliez comprendre ce que ça
fait sur votre pouvoir d'achat et leur
parti et puis ce soir elle a fait des
images
donc les gens ont trouvé ça formidable
parce qu'on est dans une société d'image
et puis ce soir elle a fait un
communiqué pour donner ses solutions
et puis elle a dit que si besoin et elle
a ressorti son programme pour les pme
qui n'a rien à voir avec moi le pool
mais ça n'est pas grave elle n'est pas
dans le réel est derrière elle a dit
s'il fallait qu avec l urd poule serait
sauvée parce qu'on nationalise ray
alors
j'ai vécu de près et comme disent de
grands auteurs contemporains qui ne sont
pas michel audiard il y en a qui ont
essayé ils ont eu des problèmes
mais qu'est-ce que cela dit qu'elle veut
faire vivre cette fracture politique en
attisant les haines en entend en parlant
aux peurs pour les utiliser mais en
n'apportant aucune réponse rien face à
cela nous devons avoir le discours de la
responsabilité de l'exigence aller au
contact accepter les invectives parfois
la colère parce qu'elle est toujours
légitime et qu'elle dit quelque chose
mais ne cédez rien de la vérité c'est à
ce prix que nous résorberons cette
fracture
cris à la fracture démocratique ensuite
elles sont nourries injustement laquelle
est elle le fait que tant et tant de nos
concitoyens n'ont plus confiance se
disent tous les élus ou les politiques
sont à mettre dans le même sac il ne
valait plus rien bien sûr il ya eu des
excès des cases injustifiée et
injustifiable
bien sûr que comme vous je sais cette
campagne dans laquelle nous sommes
beaucoup de choses ont été faites une
très large majorité d'élus sont
exemplaires donnent de leur temps de
leur énergie de leur disponibilité pour
une large majorité de manière bénévole
ne l'ait l'on ne les laissons pas salir
mais surtout nous apporterons une
réponse concrète sorte une vraie loi de
moralisation de notre vie politique qui
empêchera les conflits d'intérêts les
emplois de complaisance qui mettra un
cadre clair sur les rémunérations et qui
permettra de sortir de la démagogie et
d'aller au bout du travail de
clarification de transparence nous
apporterons une réponse en renouvelant
la vie politique et en faisant monter de
nouveaux talents de nouveaux visages
parce que c'est cette promesse qui est
la nôtre
[Applaudissements]
mais ne vous trompez pas le front
national il est ce qui se nourrit de
cette fracture démocratique
il a les pires pratiques de l'ancien
régime
madame le pen elle est l'héritière de ce
système
elle est née dans un château de partie
et donne des leçons elle se prétend du
peuple mais tu mérites l'heure elles
viennent à partie qui constamment
constamment a refusé de respecter les
lois de la république
elle refuse de se soumettre aux juges de
la république française regardez dénoncé
dites-leur à celles et ceux qui n'y
croient plus elle n'est pas la réponse
[Applaudissements]
à
il ya la fracture sociale on en parle
depuis 20 ans et elle est essentielle
elle reste là et oui on ne peut pas
faire réussir le pays
six années la réussite que de
quelques-uns alors oui je porte un
projet avec vous de réussite des
métropoles des talents et nous en avons
besoin
parce qu'ils tirent tout le pays nous
avons besoin d'une politique de
recherche et d'innovation ambitieuse
nous avons besoin d'une politique de
libération des énergies de libération de
droit du travail nous avons besoin d'un
vrai dynamisme économique parce qu'ils
tirent tout le pays
mais cette politique ne vaut que si nous
savons regarder en face la détresse des
classes moyennes et des classes
populaires
j'écoutais tout à l'heure nous étions à
bully-les-mines un ancien salarié me
raconter son expérience dans une
entreprise de la région et me dire qu'il
ya 20 ans avec le même travail
il emmenait sa famille en vacances et
qu'aujourd'hui il ne le peut plus on ne
peut pas ne pas entendre cela les doutes
ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure à
whirlpool ce que j'ai réentendu dans le
bassin minier à wattrelos il ya quelques
mois
les gens qui disent il ya plus de place
pour moi dans ce monde moi j'ai pu
bénéficier du système
à 50 ans je ne vaut plus rien ou bien
mes enfants n'auront pas de place
cette fracture sociale elle est là mais
ça n'est pas être de gauche ou de droite
c'est d'être au pays d'avoir la france
au coeur que de répondre à ce défi est
de dire qu'il n'ya pas de réussite d'un
pays
six années la réussite que de
quelques-uns regardez ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis en grande bretagne les
classes moyennes et les classes
populaires ont dit non l on dise cette
mondialisation elle n'est plus fait pour
nous votre système
on n'y a plus notre place et donc nous
devons apporter une réponse la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des français
c'est une réponse de pouvoir d'achat
pour les classes moyennes c'est la
priorité que je porterai
avoir une vraie réforme du marché du
travail qui protège dans l'entreprise
par un dialogue social constructif dans
l'entreprise et la branche pour conforme
qu'on protège qu'on ne trouve les bonnes
règles c'est donner une place aux
classes moyennes et aux classes
populaires qui travaillent par le
travail et dans le travail
avoir une politique de formation
professionnelle transformé qui ira vers
les chômeurs vers les moins qualifiés
investir massivement
15 milliards d'euros sur le quinquennat
sur les plus fragiles qu'ils soient
jeunes ou non c'est une réponse pour les
classes moyennes c'est réduire cette
fracture sociale c'est à dire vous
quitte en scène d'avoir plus de place
vous n'aurez pas du jour au lendemain
mais je vais vous protégez vous pas
l'emploi qui n'existe plus pas vous
faire des fausses promesses non nous
allons ensemble vous redonner une place
dans la société par le travail par une
formation qui débouchera sur un emploi
un vrai un emploi d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
c'est cela le projet que nous portons à
il est ambitieux il est long il est dur
et on le sait bien
je vois là mes amis du valenciennois de
saint-omer vous le vivez depuis des
années sur les territoires je l' ai vécu
votre indignation votre colère quand une
entreprise décidé de fermer ou de
restructurer parce qu'il ya un moment
c'est insupportable
mais ce travail lent de reconstruction
en revitalisant des sites en formant
vous l'avez menez vous avez fait émerger
un visage d'une france numérique dans
des territoires où plus personne ne
pariez en qualifiant les gens en
qualifiant les salariés la réponse elle
n'est pas dans la démagogie
elle est dans cette ambition collective
dans cet investissement dans l'homme
dans l'entreprise dans la machine dans
ce qui est le coeur d'un projet pour
produire au 21ème siècle
et puis réduire cette fracture sociale
c'est aussi l'école s'est formé parce
que quand on n'est pas fort mais on n'a
pas d'avenir et cela le front national
n'en ai jamais un mot rien
alors oui nous avons un projet ambitieux
pour donner plus de moyens là où il y en
a besoin pour recréer l'égalité des
chances a menés à douze élèves en classe
de cp ce1 dans les zones dites
rappellerai plus là où il ya de la
pauvreté
là où il y a des difficultés donner plus
d'autonomie pour contruire donnés par
l'école les moyens de réussir
la fracture sociale c'est comme ça qu'on
l'a résorbera vraiment c'est un travail
au coeur du pays au quotidien éminemment
difficile mais c'est celui que nous
mènerons parce qu'il n'y a aucune autre
réponse à la division du pays à cette
fracture là aucune autre
il ya aussi la fracture territoriale on
la voit partout et vous y êtes en plein
cette fracture territoriale
elle touche les banlieues la ruralité
les quartiers et les territoires qui se
sont d industrialiser le bassin minier
où nous étions tous ces territoires
qu'on sépare trop souvent ils ont une
communauté de destin l'activité
économique est parti le doute s'est
installé et les chances de réussir ne
sont pas les mêmes ne sont plus les
mêmes
cette fracture territoriale elle
n'aurait la fracture politique elle est
là alors moi ce que je veux avec vous
c'est donner à tous ces territoires la
même chance pour réussir demain la même
possibilité de faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là aussi ne nous y trompons pas ça ne se
fera pas en un jour
ça se fera avec vous les élus de terrain
les grands élus parce que les grands
élus sont là au quotidien apporte et
d'engueulades et de gifles au contact du
réel avec les forces vives économiques
sociales c'est vous qui le ferait avec
les régions avec les villes les
départements nous le ferons ensemble
avec humilité mais détermination cette
égalité des chances
je veux d'abord la reconstruire en
redonnant légalité des accès 18 mois
seront laissés aux opérateurs de
téléphonie pour déployer partout la
fibre ou la 3g la 4g
ensuite l'état prendra ses
responsabilités et déploiera lui-même
par le plan d'investissement que nous
avons décidé ensuite sur la santé nous
doublerons le nombre de maisons de santé
parce qu'il faut lutter contre les
déserts médicaux
parce que je ne veux plus que des écoles
se ferme dans la ruralité
nous les maintiendront
parce que nous rouvrirons des maisons de
services au public pour là aussi partout
garder ce maillage cette présence au
coeur des territoires des services
publics
parce que nous aurons surtout ces
territoires une politique qui permettra
de réussir dans l'artisanat le commerce
en supprimant le rsi en libérant les
règles
[Applaudissements]
mais parce que là de toutes les réformes
déjà porté et dont j'ai tant parlé sur
le plan économique dont ces territoires
ont aussi besoin
nous devons aller plus loin nous devons
investir
je veux que dans tous ces territoires
urbains on puisse reprendre une vraie
ambition celle qu'un enfant du pays de
coeur et un grand responsable avait
porté en son temps avec l'anru jean
louis borloo je les dis je veux rétablir
je veux rétablir un vrai budget de
l'anru et il sera donc doublé pour que
nous repartions avec une vraie politique
de cohésion urbaine
parce que la réponse pour nos
territoires est double c'est
reconstruire la ville refaire les
quartiers refaire de bons quartiers pour
y vivre dignement et dans le même temps
permettre pour celles et ceux qui le
veulent de la mobilité géographique et
sociale c'est-à-dire par l'école par le
travail et par l'emploi permettre aussi
que celles et ceux qui veulent quitter
ses quartiers pour aller ailleurs le
puisse mais aujourd'hui c'est la double
peine
l'assignation à résidence et la pauvreté
nous casserons ces deux murs pas avec de
fausses promesses avec la mobilité
économique et social et avec une vraie
politique urbaine et de cohésion
[Applaudissements]
et dans les territoires les plus en
difficulté ou la désindustrialisation
est là qu ils soient ruraux périurbains
ou autre je mettrai en place dès les
premiers mois du quinquennat une
stratégie de reconquête forte avec de
nouveaux instruments
ce que je veux au delà des mesures déjà
annoncées
c'est un vrai plan marshall de la
réindustrialisation de nos territoires
économiquement perdu
ça veut dire que dans le bassin minier
que dans le valenciennois cachette au
thierry et que dans ces territoires que
nous connaissons tous ici nous mettrons
en place des zones franches économique
pour permettre à des entreprises de
s'implanter avec en contrepartie des
obligations dans la durée dans gauche et
d'investissement avec le droit laissé
aux pouvoirs publics et je le dis dès le
début avec le droit laissé aux pouvoirs
publics d'aller rechercher ces aides
si le compte n'y est pas à la fin
je ferai dans ces territoires et dans le
cadre de ce plan marshall des
territoires en difficulté des
territoires d'expérimentation qu'est ce
que cela veut dire des nouvelles
technologies arrivent et on le sait
aussi
pour ce qui concerne la mer cher
frédéric le boulonnais on en connaît les
difficultés
or des technologies nouvelles sont là
des filières nouvelles arrivent qui
permettront d'exploiter différemment la
mer nous devons en france pouvoir les
essayer
les développer et bien aujourd'hui les
règles sont trop contraignantes trop
lente
je ne veux plus des mêmes règles partout
sur le territoire je veux qu'on puisse
expérimenter essayé dans certains
territoires pour un temps donné
eh bien ce sera dans ces territoires de
la république qui aujourd'hui pense
qu'ils n'ont plus d'avenir qu'on
essaiera l'avenir
et quand le sort
[Applaudissements]
parce que ces terres là qu'elle soit de
l'est du nord du centre de du sud de
l'ouest
nous les connaissons ce sont les
vieilles les vieilles terres
industrielles et agricoles de notre pays
je les connais comme vous vous en êtes
ce sont des femmes et des hommes qui ont
le travail au coeur qui veulent la
dignité dans le travail et par le
travail qui souffrent de quoi de ne plus
avoir cette dignité de ne plus penser
l'avenir donc l'avenir non seulement
nous en avons un
mais nous nous reconstruirons là nous
irons reconquérir la
[Applaudissements]
à
alors je vous le dis je ferai tout pour
me battre à vos côtés sans faire des
promesses folles que je ne saurais pas
tenir
il y aura d'autres entreprises fermées
il y aura des échecs et nous les
subiront nous nous battrons à chaque
fois dans la dignité et dans la vérité
et je serai toujours à vos côtés au
maximum
mais surtout nous avons un avenir et
c'est cela ce que je veux dire ce soir
en face au wild poule o goodyear à
toutes celles et ceux que je connais
dans cette région si bien aux sambre et
meuse sur lesquels j'ai échoué à tous
les salariés de la sidérurgie
on nous n'avons pas toujours réussis et
d'autres fois un peu aux salariés d'arc
que je n'oublierai jamais à toutes
celles et ceux qui se battent qui aiment
ce territoire est alors élu je dis une
chose on n'y arrivera pas à chaque fois
mais à chaque fois on se battra par
contre je vous le dis
l'avenir du pays on le construira avec
vous je vous y donnerait une place en
vous formant je vous y donnerait une
place en investissant nous y aurons une
place parce que nous ferons nous
innoverons et nous le ferons là avec
vous pour notre pays
[Applaudissements]
dimanche soir les français ont décidé
une chose de sortir des vieilles
querelles
nous ne serons pas d'accord sur tout
c'est sûr mais le choix de l'avenir de
l'espoir dû développement c'est le nôtre
alors nous n'avons aujourd'hui plus
d'autre choix pour éviter la haine et le
repli plus d'autre choix que de porter
cet espoir cette volonté de conquête
nous le ferons avec nos différences je
serai le garant de cette unité
et croyez moi j'irai au bout mais ce
combat nous le mènerons jusqu'à son
terme parce que nous n'avons pas d'autre
choix
[Applaudissements]
la fracture qui reste ensuite c'est
celle entre la france et l'europe
elle nourrit tous ces mensonges le front
national sans alimentent cette fracture
là elle a prospéré sur le mensonge
français depuis tenté tant d'années
dès qu'il ya une difficulté on va
expliquer que c'est la faute de
bruxelles que c'est la faute de l'europe
non c'est une autre faute parce que
bruxelles c'est nous c'est un choix
souverain c'est le nôtre avant tout
alors je vous le dis est ce que nous
pouvons aujourd'hui sortie de l'europe
et de l'euro
je le dis non seulement à vous aux
salariés qui doute à ceux qui ont peur
ce canton la défendons la ces dans les
quinze jours que tout se passe le projet
de madame le pen c'est quoi sortir de
l'euro
ça veut dire que votre épargne demain
elle perdra au moins 30 % de ce qu'elle
vaut ça veut dire que vos salaires
diminueront en vrai ils seront dans une
autre monnaie mais ce que vous consommez
vient en majorité de l'étranger et donc
cette monnaie ne changera pas le coût de
tout ce que nous importons augmentera et
donc nous nous appauvrir on a pas celles
et ceux qui vivent dans des châteaux les
classes moyennes les classes populaires
elles s'appauvriront chaque jour qu'elle
consomme elle s'appauvrit rond
sur leur épargne c'est cela la sortie de
l'euro et je ne cèderai rien
ensuite sortir de l'europe mais qu'est
ce que cela veut dire
le protectionnisme c'est la guerre c'est
un mensonge c'est le repli sortir de
l'europe mais gti est donc quelques
instants à amiens je leur ai dit il y
avait un salarié de whirlpool qui
étaient là vous avez vu l'entreprise à
côté procter & gamble 1000 salariés
formidable entreprise d'un groupe
international et à amiens
amiens n'est pas foutu il répond oui mon
fils y travaillent je lui dis le site de
procter & gamble à amiens 90 % de ce
qu'il fabrique est exporté hors de
france
c'est le site pour l'europe sortons
l'europe si procter & gamble à amiens
c'est fini et dans chaque ville je peux
vous donner des entreprises ce type
mais surtout ce protectionnisme
économique sur le plan politique c'est
le nationalisme est là dessus ne vous y
trompez pas le front national ça n'est
pas le parti des patriotes c'est le
parti des nationalistes et les
nationalistes c'est la guerre
les patriotes ils aiment leur pays ils
l'aiment ouvert à l'image de ce qu'il
est de ce qu'il a toujours été
la france est un peuple fier qui s'est
construit par la langue à villers
cotterêts qui s'est renforcé dans son
histoire sa tradition mais qui a
toujours aspiré à l'universel
la france c'est une langue qui se parle
sur tous les continents c'est un pays
dont les valeurs ont irrigué toutes les
démocraties
c'est une puissance qui a toujours tiré
les autres de l'avant la france c'est
tout sauf le rétrécissement et je vous
le dis ce soir j'ai mal dans ma chair et
dans mes racines de voir le chiffre du
front national dans les hauts de france
et je vous le dis
parce que c'est notre responsabilité ici
à quelques kilomètres d'ici
ma famille pour moitié est enterré à
othis dans une vallée triste que je n'ai
visité que pour les enterrements et mon
arrière grand père était maire cette
vallée je les connais très bien
ses paysages aux confins de la somme et
du pas de calais j'en connais les
charmes la tristesse et les souffrances
ce pays ce pays où nous sommes il a
connu toutes les guerres de l'europe
toutes les guerres de flandre les
guerres qui ont décimé le moyen âge les
siècles qui ont suivi les deux grandes
guerres qui ont fait notre siècle ou qui
ont à un moment faille et le défaire
nous avons été au coeur à chaque fois et
tout à l'heure à bully-les-mines je n'ai
pas oublié cette médaille voyez qu'on
m'a donnée celle de notre dame de
lorette
mais au nom de quoi toutes ces femmes et
ces hommes sont tombés des discours de
haine de la bêtise humaine d'un choix
fait à un moment par des dirigeants de
manière folle de dire nous valons mieux
que le voisin
alors allons y détruire mais elles ont
le détruire avec la chair des autres
madame le pen et ses amis ils seront
réfugiés au château de montretout mais
ce sont vous et vos enfants qui rompt la
faire la même guerre qui en a fait
tomber tente étant alors le sais j'en
passe alors ils ne passeront pas alors
moi je l'envoie alors que toutes celles
des sols qui aujourd'hui ont décidé
d'être les somnambules 21e siècle au
terrain nous nous sommes debout
nous sommes en marche et nous irons au
bout avec responsabilité mais je veux
autre chose avec vous pour mon pays mais
passa passa passa
[Applaudissements]
alors oui vous l'avez compris ce sera
dur ce sera long mais nous le ferons
j'en veux aux commentateurs qui ne voit
pas la situation dans lequel le pays
j'en veux à celles et ceux qui se
demandent comment leurs intérêts demain
seront recomposée et je ne lui en
voudrai à nous de ne pas être à la
hauteur du moment
cela veut dire que notre responsabilité
est immense de dire la vérité de ne
céder à aucune facilité mais de savoir
aussi rassembler notre responsabilité ma
responsabilité dans les quinze jours
dans les semaines qui suivent et les
années qui viennent ce sera d'abord de
recréer l'unité du pays
pas pour dire que notre pays est devenu
un grand tout il n'ya plus de différence
mais de réconcilier vraiment au delà de
ces fractures et de rassembler largement
tous les progressistes qui veulent
travailler ensemble honnêtement pour
faire je vous le dis je mettrai dans les
quinze jours qui viennent toute mon
énergie à aller partout dans le terrain
au contact des français
partout où il ya de la colère pour
l'entendre l'écouté dire notre vérité et
notre projet et vous m'aiderez j'en
aurai besoin
et je mettrai la même volonté à
rassembler toutes celles et ceux qui
veulent travailler avec moi de manière
honnête forte vigoureuse sur un projet
cohérent
celui que nous portons un projet
volontariste où chacune et chacun aura
sa place où chaque volonté aura son rôle
parce que j'aurai besoin de toutes les
volontés et que ce défi là ça ne sera
pas le défi d'un homme ça n'aurait aucun
sens ni le défi d'un clan encore moins
celui d'un parti c'est celui d'un pays
c'est celui d'une génération
le peuple de france a dit dimanche soir
qu'il voulait tourner une page mais il a
dit aussi et avant tout qu'il croyait
dans l'avenir qu'il croyait dans
l'espoir qu'ils croyaient dans
l'optimisme
notre responsabilité c'est de faire
gagner largement
seulement généreusement ce camp là qui
est le camp de la france le 7 mai
prochain
c'est de le faire tous ensemble avec
dignité et dans l'unité et donc oui mes
amis
face à toutes ces fractures je veux être
le président d'une unité retrouvée et
d'une france réconciliée
face à toutes ces colères et ses doutes
je veux être le président de la
reconnaissance de la dignité et de la
reconnaissance morale de chacune et
chacun
face à l'inefficacité qui produit la
haine la colère et les fractures
je veux répondre par une politique
efficace et juste
celle que nous mènerons pour les classes
moyennes et populaires pour les
territoires pour l'école pour la
reconquête pour l'égalité des droits
mes chers amis
mes chers amis ne vous trompez pas
entendez la colère respecter les
divisions mais partout à les convaincre
et je le dis à tous nos concitoyens
je sais ce qui nous différencie
j'ai bien conscience que j'ai pu parfois
vous gênez que vous ne vous retrouviez
pas dans mon projet que vous n'êtes pas
tout à fait à l'aise mais regardons
ensemble le défi qui est celui du pays
je veux reconstruire notre unité pour
faire je veux être un président qui
protège qui assure la sécurité qui est
construit qui transforme et qui avec
vous reconquiert cela prendra des années
mais j'ai besoin de vous
alors mes amis dans les quinze jours qui
viennent ne néglige rien je vous le dis
ne donnez pas au front national
votre colère il ne la mérite pas ne
donnez pas au front national
vos espoirs ils les trahira ne donnait
pas au trot nationale vos indignations
parce qu'ils sont nourries sans y
répondre
je veux avec vous construire le projet
de la france qui entendra vos colères
qui saura nos différences mais qui
construira notre unité dans l'exigence
pour faire pour créer pour enfin être
fier d'être français en europe d'être
nous ensemble
vive la république vive la france
voilà pour ce meeting emmanuel macron
qui avait lieu hier soir arras nous
allons le commenter avec deux invités
toujours présents en plateau notre
chroniqueur économique jean louis
gombeaud bonjour jean louis bonjour rien
notre éditorialiste politique n'est
qu'elle avait ce rebond jour michael
alors on vient d'entendre ce discours d'
emmanuel macron près d'une heure de
discours
une heure de discours pendant lesquelles
et bien il a clairement ciblé attaquer
son adversaire le front national mais
c'est une véritable charge contre le
front national point par point il est
allé dans le détail de ce que peut
proposer le front national pour le
démonter finalement on en est même venu
jusqu'à l'ennemi jusqu'à la guerre
jusqu'à la colère des français
il ya d'autres éléments également dans
son discours dont on va parler mais
c'est vrai que la charge menée contre le
front national
c'est l'ennemi c'est l'adversaire
affiché dans l'autre de tours alors il
est allé chercher aussi les français sur
les territoires sur cette france coupée
en deux sur je vous ai entendu également
je dirais vous voir sur ce territoire là
où le front national a fait son nid
finalement là où on parlait beaucoup de
cette france des oubliés là où marine le
pen a réussi à engranger un maximum de
voix lors de l'élection présidentielle
emmanuel macron a donc décidé d'aller à
la rencontre de cette france emmanuel
macron qui a appelé les électeurs en
colère qui pourraient tenter par ce vote
front national ne donnait pas au front
national votre colère et ne la mérite
pas accédez alors il a parlé d' ennemi
on se rappelle françois hollande
mon ennemi l'adversaire c'est la finance
lui son ennemi c'est le front national
il le dit carrément est d'ailleurs à la
fin de son discours quand il dit ils ne
passeront pas passa passa passa ils ne
passeront pas c'est exactement ce que
disaient les républicains espagnols
pendant la guerre civile
no pasaran contre le fascisme de du
général franco donc c'est quand même
très très fort il dit pratiquement je
suis certain que il n'est pas possible
qu'il n'ait pas pensé à ce mot d'ordre
des républicains espagnols no pasaran
est là et le il emploie effectivement
derrière sur la tribune y'a marx et pu
en marche
c'est ensemble ces termes on est on est
dans une autre dans une nappe à une
autre démarche
les sbires et tout son discours est
structurée sur le problème de la
fracture de l'unité
nationale en disant le front national
s'appuie sur les fractures pour encore
plus ou fracturés alors que moi je
constate les fractures et je vous
propose qu'on y aille ensemble et qu'on
résolve les problèmes ensemble
je trouve qu'il a quelque part fortement
bien démoli
si je puis dire les propositions s'il y
en a de marine le pen
mais à part une ou deux nouvelles qui
n'avait pas prononcé jusque là il était
plutôt faible sur les propositions
concrètes
en revanche quand il quand il a dit il a
eu un grand projet le plan marshall de
réindustrialisation de la france bon la
formule peut pas peut paraître banal
mais il a quand même dans son programme
50 milliards de dépenses de relance et
de réindustralisation avec la création
de zones franches dans lesquelles les
parce qu'il vit il sort de whirlpool
dans cette histoire dans lequel
effectués dans ces zones franches
installeront des usines avec aides
publiques avec contrepartie ce qui est
des contre parties donc stipulé le
problème c'est que quand par exemple il
ya une contrepartie qui avaient été
données pour le cic eux
mais le problème c'est que dans son
programme il va transformer le cic eux
en baisse de charges c'est à dire que
c'est pas disons une un transfert
d'argent public vers les entreprises
c'est le fait qu'elle perd au moins deux
charges pour une somme équivalente de
l'ordre de 40 milliards et là c'est très
difficile puisque vous baisser les
charges donc voulait baisser sans
contrepartie de demander en échange des
contreparties vous parliez un des
attaques contre le programme de marine
le pen contre des points du programme de
marine le pen il a notamment attaqué
marine le pen bien sûr sur sa volonté de
sortir de l'euro sur sa volonté de
sortir de l'union européenne et il a dit
le protectionnisme c'est la guerre c'est
un mensonge c'est le repli exactement
alors là il revient un petit peu quand
même quelque part à ce qu'avait dit
françois mitterrand sans reprendre la
fort la formule il dit pas le
nationalisme c'est la guerre il dit le
protectionnisme c'est la guerre est
effectivement là vous êtes dans une
situation d'affrontement d'affrontements
total et il montre bien à travers une
autre usine qui est établi autour de la
région dab l'air qui exporte 90% de sa
production alors c'est vrai dans le cas
de vire poule
il y a des perdants dans le cas de cette
entreprise qui exporte 90%
il y a des gagnants et c'est vrai que la
france de chirac parlait de la fracture
sociale
maintenant on est on va encore plus loin
il reprend l'idée de la fracture sociale
mais on est dans la fracture sociale
on est dans la fracture se la fracture
économique et on est dans la fracture
politique aujourd'hui lors d'une triple
fracture
y a qu'à regarder la carte électorale
michael codesa mieux que moi mais quand
on regarde la carte électorale
on voit bien à quel point la france est
fracturée avec des véritables maintenant
des véritables bastions du front
national qui nous on voit bien qu'il ya
des fossés et donc son projet
c'est ensemble à dire essayons de
résoudre non seulement la fracture
sociale mais de de résoudre de réduire
en tout cas toutes les autres fractures
justement nicollin ce terme de deux
fractures c'était le fil conducteur de
ce discours d' emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron qui a parlé de trois fractures
d'abord la fracture politique
ensuite la fracture sociale puis la
fracture territoriale mais ça vous
rappelle pas quelqu'un
je me rappelle surtout jacques chirac
1995 la fracture sociale qui avait fait
toute cette campagne dessus et quelque
part on retrouve un peu d'événements de
jacques chirac
chez emmanuel macron il n'ya qu'à
prendre également son slogan de campagne
la france ensemble
le second de jacques chirac en 2002
c'était la france en grand la france
ensemble il ya quelques similitudes dans
son discours effectivement trois grandes
fractures aujourd'hui trois grandes
fractures qui met en opposition avec le
rassemblement c'est ce qu'il souhaite
aujourd'hui il veut rassembler élargir
l'unité du pays réconcilié il avait
décidé de faire l'opposition à cette
fracture avec des mots qui sont deux
mots d'apaisement finalement démo de
protection il veut être
il veut incarner le président protecteur
marine le pen avait décidé de faire sa
campagne sur la france apaisée
elle avait un petit peu
fait marche arrière à la fin de la fin
du premier tour elle était repartie sur
des sujets très régaliens et notamment
sur le terrorisme sur l'immigration va
lui reprend la main sur cette france
apaisée
il se veut donc le président de la
france en ce moment oui l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises le candidat de la
france réconciliée c'est un mot qui
l'employait souvent et l'unité du pays
c'est l'unité du pays car on voit bien
encore une fois cette fracture est donc
pour résoudre cette facture il y à
l'unité il y un mois aussi qui est
revenu qui est peut-être été empruntés
je ne sais pas peut-être jean-louis vous
pourrez vous dire mes empreintes et le
mot faire ça nous rappelle également qui
françois fillon avec le site the only
faire il a repris quelque part des
éléments très importants qui était dû à
la droite il a repris la parle également
de jean louis borloo on l'a entendu jean
louis borloo sur la politique de la
ville la politique urbaine et la
cohésion
tout cela c'était ce que bout de jean
louis borloo avait mis en place donc il
y a parsemer parmi son discours tout une
reprise d'éléments très important qui
était dûe à la droite sociale à gauche
sur la sur la fracture le rassemblement
l'unité du pays donc il se veut se pose
de votre ces deux rives et pour résorber
la fracture sociale puisque il insistait
sur la fracture sociale il insistait sur
plusieurs points de son programme
l'exonération pour 80% des ménages la
taxe d'habitation une vraie réforme du
marché du travail
et surtout il s'est voulu le candidat
qui parle qui apporte des solutions aux
classes moyennes alors alors le problème
justement par rapport aux solutions
la fracture le problème c'est le ciment
pour l'instant bon alors il fait un
discours donc on va pas lui demander
d'apporter du ciment dans un discours on
va lui a demandé de la portée des mots
et c'est un discours ce discours donc
c'est des mots mais fondamentalement
évidemment le grand problème c'est le
quelle est la quantité de ciment qu'il
nous faut pour réduire les fractures
tant qu'il y en a hélas tellement donc
et sahel évidemment c'est un véritable
c'est un problème de considérables moi
je suis satisfait d'avoir entendu ceux
du sco parce que le président il a
vraiment est allé l'ensemble des
preneurs à la violence et au risque
d'apparaître plus comme un commentateur
comme un diagnostiqueur que comme un
véritable médecin c'est ça le risque
mais il faut quand même mettre tout sur
la table et ce qu'il a fait il mit tout
sur la tribune il le dit voilà il
décline l'ensemble des fractures auquel
il va se poser et donkey la plus exposée
une volonté pour reprendre un peu ce que
des et fillon dans le premier dans le
premier tour une volonté pour la fin
beaucoup plus comme une volonté comme
une méthode que comme encore une fois un
véritable ciment 50 milliards + alors là
évidemment la seule réforme structurelle
ce qu'est laquelle il a développé c'est
ce que vous venez de dire oriane c'est
la réforme du marché du travail
d'ailleurs il a il a bien il a mis ça
d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'était
volontaire aussi parce que quelquefois
il quitte ses notes donc on voit pas
trop de succès dans ses notes mais il
parle de la mondialisation
et puis il dit bon vin pour résoudre le
problème entre autres ici d'autres
choses il dit la réforme du marché du
travail
je doute que cette réforme du marché
travail il l'avait déjà dit avant même
le premier tour quand elle dit moi c'est
celle loi elle commet une puissance 10
je doute qu à vire poule ce genre de
deux solutions soit soit actuellement la
bienvenue par rapport à quelqu'un qui
vient vous dire comme madame le pen ou à
l'extrême extrême gauche
j'interdirais le licenciement l'âge il
ne fermera pas vous garderez tous votre
emploi calcul arrive et c'est pour
revenir sur sur jacques chirac il a cité
un jacques chirac une fois pendant son
discours emmanuel macron en disant je ne
reproduirai pas à l'erreur faite en 2002
par jacques chirac qui a consisté à
reprendre les habitudes manière de
montrer que lui fera la politique
autrement
mais leurs tunnels sont surtout
certainement c'est à dire qu'il fallait
ouvrir à l'époque il fallait face au
duel entre jean marie le pen et jacques
chirac
derrière il fallait faire un
gouvernement presque d'union nationale
qui n'avait pas été fait à l'époque lui
veut et un carnet et la droite et la
gauche donc sa seule solution s'il gagne
l'élection présidentielle mènent entendu
ça sera d'ouvrir à tout bout de champ et
ouvrira qui a si une forme de nouvelles
personnalités dans la vie politique de
nouveaux visages comme il dit à une
nouvelle moralisation de la vie
politique aux pratiques et aux usages
qui ne peuvent plus se faire comme elle
se faisait jusqu'à présent c'est son
pari emmanuel macron si le pari depuis
le début c'est depuis depuis que
notamment françois bayrou l'a l'a
rejoint
c'est le pari de la moralisation séparer
du renouveau
c'est le pari du et droite et gauche
pour l'instant il a marqué quelques
points sur ce terrain là il reste quand
même une dernière étape
mais contrairement en 2002 emmanuel
macron l'a noté il n'y a pas un front
républicain qui s'est soulevée comme si
les uns et les autres s'étaient habitués
au front national
alors il ya de ça bien sûr il aura pas
les 80% s'il est élu évidemment il est
dans une situation qui n'est pas celle
de de jacques chirac
à mon sens raison de plus pour justement
par rapport à ce que voulait dire avec
michael ouvrir et effectivement quand il
a débattu de corte au moment
actuellement on réfléchit sur le prime
des investitures pour les législatives
c'est à dire qu'effectivement il peut
pas être dans puisqu'il faut qu'ils
distribuent les investitures
il peut pas être dans une situation deux
pas de ce qu'il y avait un peu de la
vengeance jacques chirac en 2002 par
rapport à au clan balladur
da il peut pas être dans cette posture
là ce n'est pas possible donc
et visiblement il a alors ce qu'il a dit
il a dit qu' il n'a pas dit il a parlé
d'un pas prononcé le mot d'investiture
mais il ne donnera son aval qu'aux
personnes qui s'engagent à défendre à
son programme son projet donc c'est déjà
une base parce que jusqu'à présent on
disait il n'y aura que des candidats en
marche
non il semble bien qu'il y aura des
candidats en marche plus des candidats
qui diront que je suis d'accord avec
vous mais qu'at elle pour terminer
emmanuel macron a dit à plusieurs
reprises deux fois
notre responsabilité est immense notre
joie est grave mais notre responsabilité
est immense
ça c'était une manière de répondre à
françois hollande qui a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas eu de prise de conscience que
le front national est l'état où il avait
déjà répondu dès lundi en le disant
finalement qu' il n'avait pas de leçon à
recevoir de ceux qui ont fait monter le
front national depuis vingt ou trente
ans donc encore une fois effectivement
c'est une réponse à tous ceux qui l'ont
critiqué depuis dimanche soir oui la
conscience des responsabilités qu'ils
doivent l'attendre dans cet
entre-deux-tours aujourd'hui des
responsabilités face à la menace que
pourrait représenter le front national à
ses yeux
oui aux responsabilités qui doivent
s'engager sur
les cinq années à venir s'il gagne
l'élection présidentielle oui aux
responsabilités en tout genre mais c'est
vrai qu'il répondait aussi aux critiques
qu'il avait amené dimanche soir dans un
restaurant parisien
et c'est vrai que hier avec l'image
qu'on a vu la communication autour de
damien et deux devant l'usiné à
whirlpool
il a peut-être réussi à tourner cette
page la page de la rotonde on va
l'appeler comme cela merci michael merci
jean louis d'avoir été avec nous pour
commenter ce meeting d'emmanuel macron
qui avaient donc le hier soir arras on
se retrouve demain midi pour suivre
cette fois le meeting de marine le pen
la candidate du front national qu'israël
ce soir en meeting à nice très bonne
journée à tous sur public sénat
[Musique]